dune I cannot wait I'm a huge fan of
Danny's work it seems like he works with
the best cinematographers who are alive
right now so I mean I think it's a
testament to that that he reached out to
you for dune but what was that
experience like and what can you tease
about that sci-fi epic
I can tell you the DNI's a master and
and lovely human being who is passionate
and wild and sensitive and loving and
you know one other Bethany is French
Canadians and Australians tend to have a
lot of similarities in that you know we
meet we tend to get a little bit we can
get a bit
most passionately aggressive you know
when it needs me we need to be like it's
yeah it's like it's like a the French
Canadians a convene very very passionate
about about their back life and things
and so I found getting on him with him
really well on there and Patrice the
production is ona because well I think
we all had the same thing if you know
something wasn't could be like [ __ ]
yeah Tracy like great this [ __ ] like
awesome and made the same relationship
so starting to come out and it's it was
quite an adventure visually um it was a
beautiful experience making it the
people involved in that
I just we're just like overwhelmed with
you know some of the actors as well as
being so many talented actors were just
lovely lovely people hurt you know I've
become very close to since then and I'm
working on a few little side projects
with ya which I can't touch about it
but yeah and that's really really
interesting it looks it looks incredible
I know the plan is to do a two-part is
the kind of scale of this one pretty
large pretty vast or is it kind of like
a setup for you know the second half of
the story and it's it's a it's a fully
film story in itself but with places to
go so it's a it's not a it's a it's a
it's a fully standalone epic film on
that paper will we'll get the line out
of when they see it and it's a
standalone I'm not gonna one animun so
is it interesting for you coming from
rogue one and the mandalorian which you
know are sci-fi stories but very much in
your working in a an established sci-fi
universe that to then go into something
like dune which is also sci-fi but you
know now there are different rules in
terms of what the production design of
the world looks like what the costumes
of play definitely it's quite it was
quite fun because um I had to forget a
lot of Star Wars when I was making dude
it wasn't hard though because you know
Denis and I we was speaking very clearly
about how the film should look and
should feel and the formats and the this
and than that so it was not hard to to
swerve and change lanes you know there
was some similarity it's like the
deserts and the this and there that like
I mean listen ultimately
I'm positive a George Lucas inspired by
June when he wrote Star Wars I again I
you know and if that's a justice talk
about that but this is there are a lot
of similarities in some areas you know
he was definitely yeah telling he was
definitely influenced by that so
I had to be careful doing both of those
both those things that I was interested
in doing but not to repeat myself also
not not for the sake of the movie also
just for fun like I'd hate him
do the same thing twice